there's nothing quite as unsatisfying as
a bad comedy an awful horror flick might
provide some unexpected laughs and an
atrocious action film might have a few
impressive stunts but watching someone
who's supposed to be funny and failing
in every possible way is just downright
painful from pathetic sequels to
ill-advised passion projects here are
some of the cringe-worthy comedies that
bombed with a zero rating on Rotten
Tomatoes true memoirs of an
international assassin if you visit
Kevin James's page on Rotten Tomatoes
you'll see a lot of green splotches but
if you're looking for the ultimate Kevin
James calamity then head over to Netflix
and check out true memoirs of an
international assassin the worst
reviewed film of the comedians career
this 2016 film follows James as a
schlubby writer who pens a best-selling
novel about an international assassin
unfortunately his publisher is marketing
the book is nonfiction so everybody
thinks James is a real-life assassin as
a result he's kidnapped and taken to
Venezuela where he finds himself in the
middle of a deadly game involving South
American revolutionaries and a Russian
gangster I punched you punch like a
small child honestly it's not a bad
premise but the execution is completely
lackluster the a/v Club described the
film as a poor man's Edgar Wright movie
while Roger Ebert calm noted that it
keeps using the same gags over and over
all nighter the 2017 film all-nighter
finds JK Simmons plane an ultra manly
dad whose daughter has disappeared so he
teams up with her ex-boyfriend a banjo
loving hippie played by Emile Hirsch as
they look for her they encounter a whole
host of bizarre characters while Simmons
teaches Hersh how to be a real man aside
from its very specific views on manhood
critics agreed the movie suffers from
some shoddy directing and a weak script
a man should know how to drive I have
the bicycle oh well congrats on that
it's actually considered very masculine
in a Netherlands as Derrick Smith of
slant magazine put it all nighter jumps
back and forth from mystery to
mismatched buddy movie to inspirational
redemptive drama and sadly it can't
stick any of its land
still Simmons does his best to get
audiences laughing because slump or no
slump the man is always a pro the con is
on the Khan is on boasts a pretty
incredible cast led by uma Thurman Tim
Roth Alice Eve and Sofia Vergara the
plot revolves around Thurman as a con
artist who owes money to a dangerous
kingpin so she decides to steal a
priceless jewel from her alcoholic
husband's ex-wife but it just can't
compare to better heist films as it
relies on edgy humor that really isn't
all that edgy that impressive cast
actually weighs the movie down as the
characters are just loud eccentric and
lacking any real human elements so while
it's always nice to see you maater man
in action it's hard not to wish this
particular film wasn't trying to con
audiences into wasting an hour and
thirty minutes of their time watching it
surfer dude 2008 surfer dude was a bit
of a passion project for Matthew
McConaughey as it combined catching
waves smoking weed and walking around
without a shirt on the plot very
predictably involves a stoned surfer who
just wants to enjoy the ocean not
feeling it yeah not into it
I just want to serve keep the stove
today unfortunately mother nature and
the man are getting in the way so
McConaughey fights back with the power
of pot and as this movie co-stars Woody
Harrelson and Willie Nelson there's a
whole lot of ganja going on sadly it was
a complete wipeout with the critics but
fortunately The Lincoln Lawyer came
along in 2011 and saved McConaughey's
career
leaving surfer dude adrift in the sea of
bad Hollywood comedies look who's
talking now John Travolta's career has
seen some incredible highs and some
embarrassing lows but he arguably hit
rock bottom with look who's talking now
the final installment in the look who's
talking trilogy the series got started
in 1989 with Travolta playing a cab
driver who falls in love with a single
mom played by Kirstie Alley who has a
talking baby that sounds like Bruce
Willis in the sequel Ally and Travolta
have a daughter who sounds like Roseanne
Barr in part three we meet two bickering
dogs voiced by Danny DeVito and Diane
Keaton who eventually fall in love
multiple critics slammed the movie as a
ripoff of lady in the [ __ ] but instead
of romantic spaghetti dinners look who's
talking now is loaded with lousy quips
poop jokes and lines that feel a little
out of place in a kid's film it's def
nee you tick magnet sheesh
like you never sniffed the button the
movie also desperately tries to Pat out
its running time with jaw-droppingly bad
fantasy sequences one of which features
a pointless Charles Barkley cameo homer
and Eddie
starring James Belushi and Whoopi
Goldberg 1989's homer and Eddie has
largely been forgotten by comedy fans
and that's probably because it just
isn't funny sure it tries to be but it
also wants to be a heavy-handed drama
and while that convergence of tears and
laughter might work for some films here
it results in disaster the movie follows
a mentally challenged man named Homer
who wants to visit his long-lost parents
so he decides to hitchhike his way to
Oregon along the way he gets picked up
by Eddie a murderous maniac who's dying
of cancer and just escaped from a mental
ward
naturally the two form a friendship
learn about life and give Oscar bait
performances that involve a lot of
screaming squealing and super sappy
discussions in between the conversations
about God and the gags involving an
overweight prostitute Belushi and
Goldberg's a centricity is keep piling
up until you can't help but lose your
mind
[Music]